♪
>> Tucker: WELL, THERE IS SO
MUCH GOING ON IN THE NEWS IN THE
PAST YEAR AND HALF.
BASIC QUESTIONS HAVEN'T BEEN
ASKED LET ALONE ANSWERS.
WHY DID VOTERS ELECT PRESIDENT
TRUMP AS PRESIDENT.
IT WAS NOT THAT THEY DIDN'T
KNOW.
TRUMP GOT ELECTED BECAUSE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY WERE
DOING A TERRIBLE JOB.
BIG BUSINESS AND POLITICIAN AND
MEDIA WERE ALL ON THE SAME SIDE
AND THEY GOT RICH AND AMERICA
MOVED BACK WARD.
THERE WAS A THROBBING MIDDLE
FINGER IN THE FACE.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND TO HELP UNDERSTAND HOW BADLY
THEY SHAFTED THE COUNTRY.
HOW A SELFISH RULING CLASS IS
BRINGING AMERICA TO
A REVOLUTION.
IT IS AVAILABLE FOR PREORDER.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT UNTIL THEN
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE SHOW IS
ABOUT AND HAS BEEN B. I HOPE YOU
ENJOY THE BOOK AND SHOW.
THINK ABOUT BOOK ASIDE.
THE ELECTION HAPPENS THAT NO ONE
PREDICTED AND NO ONE BOTHERS TO
THINK THROUGH WHY IT HAPPENED.